Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday.
Aggressively unscripted video incoming,
so I am in Los Angeles for reasons that will become clear shortly
and I'm thinking right now about storytelling. So I have often said over the years
that I believe books belong to their readers.
Like I don't think it matters whether an author intended a symbolic resonance in their story
as long as it's there because we're not reading the author, we're reading the book.
Also, I don't think we should privilege the author's voice when it comes to matters outside the text
like, for instance, what happens to characters after the story ends
because I don't think that's up to the author, I think that's up to us as readers.
My books belong to me while I am working on them and then when I am finished, they don't.
Except... there are a couple problems with this worldview
One: It's a little bit disingenuous to pretend that the author isn't present in the book at all,
especially in our personality-driven culture and especially if the author has chosen to have a public life
by, for instance, participating in an 11 year long video blog conversation
And then, secondly, there's the problem that while the book belongs to the reader,
the author has to make a lot of decisions on behalf of the book
and that is true even after the book is published - which brings us to Los Angeles
So, I almost didn't sell the movie rights to The Fault In Our Stars, partly because I'd had some bad experiences in Hollywood
but partly because that book was really close to me.
A big part about what I enjoy about writing made-up stories was that they're a kind of coded autobiography
in which only I have the complete key to the code
and TFiOS not only contained parts of me that lots of people knew about like my friendship with Esther Earl
but also parts of certain traumatic experiences I'd never told anyone about.
I mean, obviously, it was exciting to imagine a movie of my book
but it was also scary to imagine some of that coded stuff being on a big screen for lots of people to watch.
Also, SO MUCH CAN GO WRONG, I mean, they could have changed the whole plot,
they could have made Hazel an 84 year old survivor of the Titanic!
That's actually a pretty good idea for a movie of the story of the Titanic but it's around this frame of an 84 year old lady
This is not an original idea...
Anyway, in the end, I sold the movie rights and I got so lucky.
I had no way of knowing that Elisabeth and Erin at Fox 2000 would be the perfect stewards for that movie
or that we would get amazing producers or the best possible screenwriters
or an amazing cast and end up with a movie I really loved.
And then we got to do it again with Paper Towns.
And then I thought "that was a good run" because Paper Towns didn't make as much money
and also because I'd decided to write this extremely quiet novel that takes place almost entirely inside of one person's head
which isn't the sort of thing that usually lends itself it film.
The big challenge for me in Turtles All The Way Down was whether I could use language
to find some sort of direct form or expression for obsessive thoughts
rather than only relying on metaphor.
I wanted to give readers not only a sense of what OCD is like, but, maybe at least a glimpse into what it is
which is, like, a profoundly non-visual thing.
But as Issac, who produced The Fault In Our Stars and Paper Towns pointed out to me
obsessive thoughts are also a non-linguistic experience
and that didn't stop me from writing the book.
So, for the last two months we've been talking about it
Is there a way to tell this story visually without relying on the old tropes
that are usually associated with portrayals of OCD?
And today, I get to announce that working with the same studio and production company that made
The Fault in Our Stars and Paper Towns, we're gonna give it a try.
That doesn't mean there will definitely be a movie but it means that there might be one
so now's the time to begin inundating me with casting suggestions
because no one - ever - reads my Twitter bio.
I am really excited for the opportunity and also the challenge of the Turtles All The Way Down movie
and I hope you're excited too.
The book does belong to you but I had to make this decision on behalf of it
I really trust the people who are working on this.
Thanks to everyone who has made this book a No. 1 New York Times Bestseller
for now 7 weeks straight.
And if you care about the book please know that I will try to listen to you throughout this process
Hank, DFTBA, I will see you on Friday.